este hecho de violencia que se juntó con
tres masas que ya llevamos esta semana
en otros estados
demuestra que seguimos teniendo un
problema serio de criminalidad
organizada en el que pues nos dio una
pausa de tres años probablemente la
pandemia pero que vuelve a resurgir en
hechos de violencia que aparte inician
en un espacio confinado que es un penal
y se van a la ciudad entonces también
habla de los nexos y la fuerza que
tienen a nivel local las organizaciones
y las personas que están recluidas en el
penal ahora qué garantías de seguridad
tienen hoy los mexicanos en un punto
como ciudad juárez que por ejemplo ha
sido azotada por la violencia durante
décadas
pero son sociedades que están bastante
acostumbradas a estos niveles de
violencia y peores
las autoridades mucho no han cambiado en
los últimos años las autoridades locales
siguen con capacidades muy reducidas
para hacer frente a estos despliegues de
fuerza de las organizaciones criminales
y no hay operativos especiales de las
fuerzas federales entonces y estos estos
hechos de violencia se pueden seguir
reproduciendo y la sociedad se tendrá
que replegar a sus hogares y esperar a
que a que no se vuelva algo común y
aquello ya pues un reforzamiento de las
fuerzas federales para que haya mayor
vigilancia y por lo tanto pueda haber
mayor tranquilidad decía que se que se
están acostumbrando los mexicanos a este
tipo de hechos violentos es decir se ha
normalizado
está normalizado llevamos ya más de una
década de hechos violentos serios de
ciudad juárez particularmente desde
antes con organizaciones criminales
vinculadas a la desaparición de las
mujeres
y pues bueno finalmente unos sigues la
vida diaria en cualquier hecho de
situación de violencia e inseguridad
entonces si hice una normalización hay
una degradación social y ahí finalmente
pues una convivencia de todos los días
entre los agentes los actores criminales
y la sociedad civil ahora cuáles son los
principales retos en materia de
seguridad que enfrenta el gobierno a
nivel nacional
a nivel nacional tiene que consolidar
una fuerza
policial nacional con capacidad de
despliegue con capacidad de estar en
todas las ciudades en por los momentos
que es la guardia nacional ahora tiene
un debate muy serio sobre la
constitucionalidad de unos cambios que
se quieren efectuar para escribirla a la
secretaría de la prensa nacional
por un lado tiene eso por otro lado
tiene que fortalecer a las policías
locales darles capacidades hay que crear
capacidades institucionales para poder
hacer frente a tantas organizaciones
criminales y la violencia que ejercen y
ir desarticulando poco a poco a esos
grandes carteles están diversificados
que tienen capacidades transnacionales y
que controlan en cierta medida el
tráfico de drogas tráfico de armas y
para alrededor de 40 delitos más a nivel
nacional